hey guys this is des defender thing here
and I'm David Griffin resident comic
book and video game guru and this is our
review of two episodes of agents of
shield the first two episodes since the
break up the magical place and see the
thing episode 11 and 12 so basically
that of all of this the biggest thing
probably to come out is there's
something unique and possibly dark and
terrifying about sky mm-hmm and that's
about it well we did learn how Coulson
in in in the first magical race how he
came back which wasn't it wasn't like a
really big reveal it was basically that
fury ordered his resuscitation right
through scientific means that they
crossed the boundaries of ethics yeah
yeah I mean because he agent Coulson's
worth it yeah I don't know why he's
worth it right and now he's resting the
fact of why he's alive and he's he
didn't he's kind of aloof lately I mean
granted he's realized he's trying to
like you know figure out everything
that's going on with him why he is the
way he is why they brought him back and
what that means but I hope they bring
back I don't know if I mean similar
Jackson's gonna show up again but like I
hope he has a conversation with him at
some point or something goes on where he
asks him why yeah he's gonna be on the
phone with him or right heroes boy yeah
maybe not even hear his voice he'll just
be responding to right i mean i thought
the particular scene was was well done
yeah i was pretty dark actually been
seen his brain and him crying out like
kill me kill me I mean I was pretty
pretty grand plot in the general scheme
in context of the whole show like they
built it up to be this big huge thing
and it's I don't know kind of a letdown
yeah I mean you know they they
fabricated this this world of him being
in the apt and it's a magical place it's
a magical place and now we get to see
what this magical place was is actually
him getting by Shepherd book from
Firefly has a braised brain the brain
reanima you know just make it we also
see that that one
one villain character ends up dying yes
the one that the girl in the flower
dress was talking yeah mmm yeah and now
she's arrested right in peterson is
still around he's not because I showed
him who thought you know we see him at
the end of the mid-season finale like
going everything's blowing up around I
mean no he can't be can't kill Peterson
that quickly so he still around we can
get him in this latest episode though I
thought we'd see him again well we don't
know if he his kid is alive or right and
we saw his um his leg yeah who's been
blown off cuz you know does this suck
out oh my leg but ya know what else
happening now she admits that she's been
sleeping around yeah you know to Coulson
which you know it was kind of
interesting for me last week so that was
kind of interesting but they have really
done much with that lately now Coulson
knows but I don't suit the big deal that
is I don't know how would see that he
said like oh don't let it get in the way
of anything with him like I don't know I
mean this is kinda having fun and sky is
special but we don't know why right we
get to see we're just kind of going
through we get to see where Fitz and
Simmons went to school I guess it's like
that I kind of like that hole that they
went to a certain school and then grant
went to a different school and they a
rivalry and yea though I thought it was
thought that was a cool idea I didn't
really care much for the episode itself
though in terms of the the one kid he'd
that i forgot the actor's name but he's
in prisoners oh he was the son everybody
was the son in prison ok ok you know and
how he was developing these these larger
ideas for the guy that sky knows who's
in her organization that we saw on the
first half of the season he's back in
the game i guess or still involved and
you know i guess you kind of feel bad
for the kid looks like now he has some
powers yeah they're making all these
like the connections and all these
little things in this season is that
sure for what permeate like with a gap
what's like that one villain it's
Gravitron Gravitron yeah you should like
a hand reach out but it's like but they
haven't gone back to them ya know it
they're kind of just teasing you but
then
nothing comes of it and I that's why I
don't understand like with skies reveals
like she's special stay away from that
girl over she goes darkness follows and
like really that deep hey come on i mean
i think the show that does too much
teasing there's not enough i need a
little excitement it was something I can
taste on the Rio or some real substance
loves justjust tâches tease tease tease
tease I mean I will say that the late
last two episodes are have been better
than previous episodes before but that's
not saying much yeah and she'll like
this that's not saying much yeah it's
not it has it and it's hard to keep
giving the excuse of like well let's
just give it times it's like it's it's
that time I'm gonna sweat episodes 11 12
and we're over halfway through the
season like it needs to do something
here and the ratings are still not very
good and anybody coming back to ya so we
know you know this gonna be reinis it's
like almost like oh is it worth watch
everything right that's a you know let
us know if it's still worth us doing
these reviews because we I don't think
we're really getting anything out of the
show right i know i saw and tell them
that it's like just to talk to you guys
about how you feel like if you're
watching this zero are you into it are
you watching it you know tentatively you
sitting there in front of your TV get
your popcorn get your dinner whatever
it's in the morning are you watching it
like for me I feel like I'm almost doing
stuff and you know behind the scenes in
the background while it's on just as
kind of like filler because I just
there's not enough substance to there
for me to care about even though i would
like to care about a Marvel agents of
shield show but I'm already know me you
and my little been talking about the
future of Marvel looking ahead we're
kind of I think more excitable maybe see
what Netflix is going to do maybe
Netflix with a daredevil show can do
more and you know bring more to the
table because it can experiment more if
like this show is not doing anything
interesting no nothing's really changed
I mean even the quote-unquote to they
reveal two big secrets in the past two
episodes and they just ended up not
being that interest right we know bill
paxton's coming on for like a 4 episode
arc sometime in the future i love dope
action you'll come a little bit you know
from aliens and but we'll see I don't
know alright guys so let's know what you
thought of the last two episodes of
agents of shield that you can post your
comments below on the website think
you're calm or our YouTube channel think
here I'll pro make sure to subscribe to
that you all come chat with us on
Twitter dennis michael myself let us
know what you think about agents of
shield here asking why are we
reviewing the show what are you doing or
Haiti to be more enthusiastic about it
have hope have faith I am NOT going to
be fake enthusiastic over something I'm
not enthusiastic about hey we're just
trying to be honest here that's all we
can do so you can come chat with us at
think hero i'm at griffin de and make
sure to check out our facebook page
that's think hero fans and make sure you
like it and post our videos on twitter
or on facebook thanks